foreign
years ago
heraclitus said the world bubbles forth
here's bubbling what is actual now
enables what is next possible the
adjacent possible
the biaser has been bubbling forth for
four billion years
of creating new possibilities in the
universe and that bubbling it's critical
that physics cannot talk at all about
bubbling new bubbles
life on earth started 4 billion years
ago it is for the first two and a half
billion years where single cell
organisms co-evolving
even my existing organisms create new
possibilities if I'm a bacterium and
you're a bacterium and I have a flat
surface I'm a possible Highway you can
walk over to get food
that's bubbling forth
so two and a half billion years after
life started six times multicell
organisms emerged a billion years after
that three and a half billions after
life started is the extraordinary
Cambrian explosion
540 million years ago for 50 million
years there was just this burst of
creativity making all of the phyla that
exists now and now we have this guy I
just I'm scared of having him in bed I
really am so I don't know what to call
him and uh it's a vote afterwards so
here's a gentler guy and I'm in love
with him look at his eyes looking at you
you know you're doing what
in order to talk about how the biosor
has been creative I have to talk about
the functions of parts of an organ
you all know your heart keeps you alive
but in particular your heart pumps blood
it's not by making heart sounds so this
means something fundamental the function
of a part
is that subset of its causal properties
that sustain the holes
your heart pumping blood on you
but doing that is jury rigging finding
subsets of causal features of use some
years ago my daughter dropped her purse
in a shallow well I took a wire coat
hanger slid it over a mop handle and I
fished out her purse anything can be
used for more than one thing
uh for example a screwdriver can be used
to screw in a screw but it's great for
scraping Putty off the wall
an engine block and have eight holes
drilled and you make an engine out of it
it's actually a superb paperweight
and much research done only by
scientists demonstrates that the corners
are sharp and can crack open a coconut
I was very proud of that so
but if you're using an engine block as a
paperweight can you deduce oh I can use
this thing to crack open coconuts you
can't
it might be a banana peel
but that means also something
fundamental finding new uses for things
jury rigging is not a computation it's
not a deduction
jury rigging is
not a computation at all computers are
the biosphere is forever innovating in
this kind of way that's not a deduction
for example there are things called
darwinian pre-adaptations
dinosaurs had scales that were evolved
from thermoregulation that were injury
rigged into flight feathers your eyes
have clear crystallines that were
perfectly normal colored enzymes and
this too means something fundamentals
we cannot deduce
what is in the adjacent possible that
the evolving biosphere will create then
become
we do not even know what can happen
in fact we can use no mathematics based
on set theory which is all of
mathematics
to deduce what the bioser is going to
become or the economy this means we are
at a fantastic third trade phase
transition in science we're Beyond
Newton we're Beyond quantum mechanics
we're beyond the Exquisite view the
Copernicus had 480 years ago that the
world of the Clockwork
the biosphere Is Not A Clockwork the
paper that just published it came out
three days ago and I'm pretty proud of
it it's it's actually worth reading
we can't deduce what is in the biosphere
and will become so we can make a
mathematical theory of the statistics of
the process I call it the theory of the
adjacent possible or tap
it's really based on one idea
things can be combined to make new
things so there's the equation m t is
the number of things in the economy at
some time now say 10 things
so how many things will be in the
economy in the next period Well if the
10 things work we'll keep them
but we could actually try to jury rig
something new out of any single thing
among the ten or out a pair of things
among the ten the printing press is a
recombination between
movable type and a wine press or any
three things or four things watch what
happens to the number of things pairs of
things when the number of things goes up
if there's ten things there's 45 pairs
of things that we might fiddle with
if there's a hundred things
those four thousand five hundred things
we might jury rig with and if there's a
thousand things there's a half a million
things we might fiddle with
therefore this process the tap process
has the property that for a long time
the number of things increases very very
very slowly then something stunning
happens
there's a hockey stick explosion and the
number of things reaches Infinity
in a finite time there's there's a
singularity and a brief burst explosion
for 40 million years of the Cambrian
explosion
the same pattern is showing up in our
own Evolution
Australopithecus flourished I'd never
know what flourishing means I guess they
had a good lunch uh in Africa 3.3
million years ago
a million and a half years later Homo
erectus had about 20 crude stone tools
watch how slowly things change a mere 30
000 years ago Crow Manion in the south
of France
had about 100 or 150 of these Exquisite
pressure flake tools
a mere 28 000 years after that
is Mesopotamia with needles and chariots
there's something interesting about the
fact of course we invented writing which
is a wonderful Story Once you have a
clay tablet it calls forth the tool
that's its complement you need a stylus
so tools to make niches for new tools
and for new jobs scribes earned a living
for quite a while This Is Us in the late
Middle Ages to now and this is us now
we have billions of tools ranging from
knitting needles to the space station
there's always an adjacent possible
once you've made a bow a crossbows in
the adjacent possible
the pattern that we saw in the Cambrian
of a long period nothing happening and
then a burst is here right now
this is the size of human habitats in
the last three hundred thousand years
the horizontal line is time before
present
on the vertical line as the logarithm of
sizes of settlements nothing happened
for 290 000 years then it burst upward
watch this the same thing's true of GDP
GDP was flat since the time of Christ in
fact for the last hundred thousand years
GDP burst up in the last two centuries
it's going up vertically now
it's wonderful we're lifting Millions
from poverty
and the theory explains it it's the same
delay and burst and there it is we start
making more complex things selling them
and we make a profit
there's another feature of all of this
that I've lived in my lifetime I I'm 83
I was born in 1939 just like the
Cambrian explosion watch the number of
things that have come into existence in
my lifetime
we didn't have any helicopters we we
didn't have television I I listened to
the Lone Ranger which maybe you know but
on radio six o'clock at night uh we we
didn't have
uh
a computers we didn't have Plastics
which are now all over the planet we
didn't have microwaves we didn't have
lasers look at the number of things that
came into existence in one lifetime of
83 years not much happened 50 000 years
ago in 83 years
so what's going on
the tap process has the following
property every time you make something
new the waiting time for the next new
things cut in half a thousand years 500
years 250 a year
six months three months we're going to
get a great acceleration
we are
so
this is tap
and watch that thing explode upward
that's it that explosion is the Cambrian
and it's where we are now
and the signatures of the uh
anthropocene are exploding upward now
all over the place this ends 25 years
ago
we need to find a better adjacent
possible we're rampaging over the planet
and the hope is in soils so I'm going to
talk briefly about compost there are
very fine composes not terribly
important
a very good compost is the Johnson Sioux
compost less land use fewer the
degradations of uh
of our forests fewer
Extinction events fewer pandemics well
let's get rid of fertilizer and the most
important point I'm going to take is
this is really bad news and good news
last year we emitted 40.5 billion tons
of carbon dioxide we have to find a way
of solving it and we can
um we can take this Johnson suit compost
and get it out across the landscape but
more fundamentally we can find good
fungal bacterial communities and we can
coat seeds with it
and sell the seeds around the planet or
we could fill
uh biochar and we can use biocharge
getter across the planet most usefully
we can take a really good fungal
bacterial Community put it into biochar
some other Matrix mix it into fertilizer
and get that fertilizer out across the
planet I'm going to just end with the
following
fungal bacterial communities are
precisely something that can create
novel adjacent possibles that can bubble
forth with solutions to soil problems
the good news is
we can do it now the planet's on fire
we are of nature ladies and gentlemen
we're not above nature thank you
thank you